[موسيقى]
اليمن
هكذا اصبحت الخارطه السياسيه بعد 22 من
مايو 1990
قبل هذا التاريخ كان اليمن دولتين
منطق التاريخ والجغرافيا وصراع الافكار
والاشخاص
انتج لنا اللحظه الراهنه
[موسيقى]
وفي فتره ما قبل الاستقلال اعلنت السلطه
البريطانيه عن تشكيل اتحاد الجنوب العربي
وهو ما ذكرته هذه الوثيقه التي كتب عليها
انها ملك حكومه صاحبه الجلاله في بريطانيا
وان تداولها محدود للغايه ولا يسمح بتصوير
هذه الوثيقه بشكل كامل دون اخذ موافقه
الوزير او لجنه رؤساء الموظفين
الاشياء التي
خلقت التفاف واسع الوطنيين هنا
ليشن النظام ضد الاستعمار
فكمل اهداف التي طرحت هو اسقاط المشروع
الفيدرالي
لمكان يسمى
بالامارات هنا
للامارات الشرقيه والغربيه مع المستعمره
كان هذا نذكر في شبابنا نحن شباب سؤال
والشعب اليمني كان من ضد هذا الاتحاد
الفيدرالينا نحن
نقدمه بسرعه على الوحده
تلبيه لهذا الهدف النبيل ليحمله كل
اليمنيين والحركه الوطنيه اليمنيه في اغلب
برامجها
ولكن ايضا كنا كان قدامنا هو تجنبا لحرب
ثالثه بين اليمنيه وانا اقول لك بصراحه
يعني لو عملت استفتاء في الجنوب في الشمال
الناس كلها كانت مع الوحده يعني لا حكايه
تحميل الرئيس عليه السلام للبيض انك انت
اللي اخذت انا وانت ذا كلام مش صحيح
الانفصال الانفصال بنفس سخافه
الوحداء والموت
بنفس يعني تفاعلت مشروع
الظلاميين الوحداء والموت اللي
حاول يخوف الناس يعني فيها وثيقه العهد
والاتفاق ارادت ان
تبني دوله تعطي اليمن كل اليمن كل مناطق
اليمن حقوقها بشكل كامل
فالفكره جاءت فكره الدوله الاتحاديه من
اقاليم متعدده مسار الوحده من الحلم الى
الانتكاسه الى سيناريوهات المستقبل
ستكون هذه رحلتنا البحثيه
[موسيقى]